after How I Met Your Mother went off the
air in 2014
alyson hannigan seemed to drop off the
face of the earth or at least our
television screens so what exactly
happened to the star while many people
were introduced to Alyson Hannigan as
American PI's Michelle aka Bandcamp girl
she's pretty well known for being a main
cast member in two super popular
television shows Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and How I Met Your Mother
in Buffy she played the role of Willow
Rosenberg a shy teenage computer geek
who grows to become a confident witch
with extraordinary powers in How I Met
Your Mother she played Lily Aldrin an
artistic teacher whose relationship with
Marshall Eriksen provides a foil for the
perpetually looking for love Ted Mosby
this is Thanksgiving solve this right
now and if you have sex again neither of
you gets dessert she was in the
spotlight as part of two highly
prominent television shows so maybe hard
to resell Hannigan to moviegoers as a
movie star rather than someone who
shines best on TV developed for CBS by
Ben Affleck and Matt Damon as a star
vehicle for comedian Tom Papa more time
with family got a ton of buzz in early
2014
just as How I Met Your Mother was
wrapping up the show was even shot on
the old How I Met Your Mother stage
except in front of a live studio
audience
ultimately the network passed on the
show which had to be a pretty massive
disappointment to Hannigan and to her
fans two years later though another
project started being widely promoted at
Hannigan's first major role after How I
Met Your Mother TV land's adaptation of
the popular 90's film First Wives Club
this version cast Hannigan alongside
smash star Megan Hilty
and Vanessa Lachey who is famous for
let's be honest marrying Jessica
Simpson's ex sadly history repeated
itself in TV land past on the show
instead moving forward with an
adaptation of Heather's this effectively
left Hannigan with two small one-off
parts on TV shows and a single
forgettable indie film is her only
credit since 2014 why spend all that
time learning lines and going on
auditions when you can make a killing
with real estate Hollywood is
notoriously fickle but property is
almost always a solid investment as
evidenced by Hannigan's growing
portfolio which made headlines in
December of 2016 after she and her
husband
Alexis Denisof picked up a new home
worth nearly eight million dollars
the couple's la pad whose distinctive
architecture was featured in the Anthony
Hopkins Ryan Gosling movie fracture is
just part of a list of properties that
includes a home in Atlanta and a rental
property in Santa Monica nothing against
any of her best-known characters but it
sounds like Hannigan may have found the
role of a lifetime
although Alyson Hannigan experienced
something of a slowdown on the acting
front since her nine-year run on How I
Met Your Mother
she's also had a lot more luck in the TV
competition series Department in 2016
she was announced as the incoming host
for the CW's magician reality show Penn
& Teller fool us hating as the title
magicians welcomed their budding peers
to try and trick them to earn a spot on
their live shows have already been
fooled once let's see if this next
magician can do it a second time for
Hannigan the gig was a good match for
her lifestyle as she said in a statement
I am so excited to be hosting a program
our whole family can watch together as a
bonus she's also gotten to watch her two
daughters learn their first magic tricks
from the pros the show which films in
Las Vegas has featured Hannigan as its
host since its third season and it
doesn't show signs of stopping anytime
soon the network renewed the series for
a sixth season in 2018 the show is far
from over for Alyson Hannigan although
her post How I Met Your Mother returned
to TV may not have panned out the way
her fans had hoped she hasn't given up
on the small screen yet in 2018 she was
cast in a recurring role for WGN
Americas second season of pure a
Mennonite crime drama in which she'll
portray a woman helping her significant
other launder money for a drug cartel
the role is a far cry from her usual
image so it should allow her to show her
audience a new side Hannigan also landed
a leading role in the Twitter thread
inspired comedy horror feature you might
be the killer
based on the viral fictional story about
a camp counselor who may or may not have
become a mass murderer she was also cast
as surgeon slash mother doctor and
possible in the Disney Channel's
live-action adaptation of Kim Possible
which means she'll have another
family-friendly film that she can screen
with their own children while her
workload might have slowed down a bit
from the old days of dominating TV she's
still keeping herself quite busy
I'm not going anywhere
[Applause]